hi guys I'm Dave here with Scott
Butterworth at Gamescom 2016 now we've
seen the same prey demo you were
quakecon me just go there Zach so why do
we talk about that a little bit yeah
totally so what what why were you
getting from from grapes when it first
booted out when we were first presented
with the demo I was like that is
bioshock dead space and dishonored in a
game yeah absolutely it's you know I'm
always reluctant to compare games
directly to other games you know
everything kind of stands on its own
everything has its own vibe but yeah
immediately upon seeing the opening area
it's a super Bioshock there's this kind
of like subdued creepiness to it it's
not really like an openly terrifying
experience but there's just like these
ominous noises and this dark lightning
like at the very beginning you see this
little spidery creature just like flit
up a staircase nearby so it's very
creepy and unsettling which was very
mention that creature the mimic yeah so
I think they've got a really cool
mechanical I don't think you can feel
safe with those existing because yeah
the jump-scares are inevitable because
they're these aliens that can mimic yeah
transform into basically any physics
based object in the game it's very easy
to kind of settle into when you can
accept expects of jump-scare like when
you play dead space you saw a necromorph
on the ground you're like that's gonna
go all right yeah it's like where is
this is like you're not going to go
through the game bashing every trash
down or kicking over every dinner plate
well you could you could it's gonna be
great it's complete yeah so no one's
going to do that so that's that's cool
that it's actually going to keep you on
your lados this game is a little bit
like dishonored in the the hero Morgan
has all these different abilities yeah
many of which he actually gets from the
aliens on the ship so there are these
items called neuro mods exactly what
they sound like they modify your neuron
via a needle through your eyes so like
the mimic alien if you scan enough of
them you can actually take that ability
and basically inject it into Morgan's
brain and once you've done that he now
has the ability to turn into any physics
based object we saw it in the demo he
turned into a cotton ball
both incredible window hilarious yeah
okay you can be given fun too small its
reversals exploration but seeing just a
coffee mug back around it's super
unexpected it's not something you really
get in a shooter and the NGC use an
unexpected ways like I said we saw them
roll through an open window then he
passed a locked door very clever at a
later point I saw Morgan turned into
like a little spherical my man go
through a room and then use some kind of
like kinetic slouch to throw the small
bowl he was up into the air into a
balcony yeah but she never could have
reached as a human so I'm really excited
to see what other powers are in the game
because just mimic on its own it's
really cool and we know that they're
going to be more things like that and
then talking to the devs you can
actually can choose to never use any of
the alien but if you want to go
completely human you absolutely can this
is very much like dishonored and that
it's player choice driven it's all about
choice and consequences it's all about
adopting a play style that fits you if
you want to just run through with guns
and kill everything you can although as
we also found out during this demo there
aren't that many done frying this game
because it's a relational exactly like
it's you're on a space station orbiting
the moon you're the product of some
experiment gone awry so you're in a
scientific setting it's not like a
military outfit like doom not lit with
machine gun yeah like there's not an
arsenal hanging out waiting for you so a
lot of the guns you introducing the game
are just repurposed scientific tools
kind of like in dead space actually the
one that we saw most prominently in the
demo called the glue cannon that looks
so much fun it's so clever as well yeah
so basically dispute like literally just
glue this is sticky paste on the enemies
and freezes them in place without
killing them but more importantly that
when the paste dries it hardens and you
can actually use this to create new pads
for yourself we saw them spray like a
diagonal line up a wall just a big ramp
going down and what that hardens you
yeah you suddenly had a new traversal
path you just built for yourself which
is really cool i love the idea that this
weapon can be used not only to
neutralize enemies but to the commercial
tool yeah it kind of reminds me of like
half I tues gravity gun could be used
like multiple things and a little bit of
thing that's always fun and satisfying
use well I'm sure there's gonna be
people out there that's combining a
dozens of powers and a glue gun and
everything else to just make basically a
mess another well it's not parents piece
of equipment was the recycler which I
thought was amazing it's like it's like
a grenade when you throw it creates like
a black hole mini black hole sucks
everything into it and out pops like
comprising materials Express resource
person left anything that's made of like
I know carbon would just be like a time
limbo cars you can then use you could
use it for exploration and moving
objects it's a good way to clear our
mimics apparently anything of hiding it
around the Sentry box when you threw it
in the demo just sucked in and it's
basically like watching a car get cubes
but you like a median to the degree yeah
it's a little long yeah that's that's
also something looks really and the
craftsman materials are very important
because I discovered that's how you
upgrade your space to yeah which allows
you to them leave the space station and
sort of fly around freely in like the
debris field surrounding talisman the
space station where you kind of wake up
there is apparently going to be combat
in in zero gravity I don't know how
that's gonna work they've really
elaborated but that is going to be a
thing it's also going to be useful for
traversal if you need to get from one
side of the space station to the other I
was told that the structure is very open
but you can go anywhere in the station
from the beginning of the game the only
thing that's going to prevent you from
doing that is you will be killed if you
try to go somewhere that's a little too
advanced for you it's like an old-school
RPG where you know it's not the games
are going to tell you not to go
somewhere but you will get murdered
because you're just not leveled or ready
to be in that area which i think is
really cool I'm looking forward to
seeing someone they like screw that
noise I gotta spoil it and then Phi the
final boss oh I guarantee there's give
me some YouTube video someone beating
the game at ten minutes to just
sprinting all the way the end I don't
think that's gonna be either that's so
good no it's I got excited about prey
absolutely i think it's looking really
cool a lot of ambitious ideas and i hope
it all comes together it's coming next
year so they got a little bit of time
but yeah we'll see all right well thanks
watching guys I've been Dean joined by
scott i'm stationed to gamespot for more
games from 2016
you